Unser universum ist ein schwarzes loch und zahlen auseinander fliegen dass dieser ansicht ist der physiker nikodem poplawski
von der university of new haven der urknall war demnach nichts anderes als das explodieren
Des kerns eines schwarzen loches wie was wo und vor allem warum jetzt sind klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Zur zeit sehen wir schwarze löcher ja als etwas extrem außergewöhnliches an in ihnen hört die normale
Physik auf und alles wird extrem licht kann nicht mehr aus ihnen entweichen und in ihrer mitte wird eine singularität
Vermutet also ein punkt ein unendlich kleiner punkt in dem alles was das schwarze loch enthält
Konzentriert ist nikotin pawlowski von der university of new haven sagt alles quatsch in der natur gibt es nichts unendliches
Deshalb gibt es auch, im schwarzen loch
Im zentrum nichts unendlich klein ist vielmehr ist es zwar extrem klein aber letztlich
Konzentriert sich dort alles auf einen endlich großen punkt mit einer zwar minimalen aber eben doch eine ausdehnung und dieser punkt
unterliegt kräften das schwarze loch rotiert und diese rotation
verhindert auch die existenz einer singularität schwarze löcher drehen sich extrem schnell fast mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
der kern des schwarzen loches wäre deshalb durch diese kräfte
Am kompletten zusammensturz gehindert und auch verändert durch die schnelle drehung und der liegt er
Wahnsinnigen kräften er verdrillt und dadurch quasi wird er wie eine feder
aufgespannt irgendwann sind die kräfte so groß dass dieser kern auseinander fliegt und sich diese kräfte die dann die
unglaubliche gravitation des schwarzen loches überwinden ihre bahn brechen und das schwarze loch fliegt eben auseinander
Genau das trifft auch auf das universum und auf den urknall zu
Genauso ist es quasi während des urknalls passiert und diese pensions- kräfte würden auch einige besonderheiten des
universums erklären so drehen sich galaxien in der einnehmendes richtung er rechts herum und in der anderen himmelsrichtungen eher links herum und
aktions achsen von quasaren sind immer, im ganzen universum
parallel phänomene die mit einer art
verknüpfung zwischen allem zu erklären sind und das wäre neben die kräfte die auf den kern eines schwarzen loches
gewirkt
hätten das universum ist inzwischen 13 8 milliarden jahre als
forschungsteams rechnen damit dass bald die ersten schwarzen löcher auf diese art und weise
Explodieren würden es wird also extrem spannend wie sich dann die
ausgeworfene materie verhält sind dort an ähnliche überreste von fusions kräften
zu finden spricht einiges dafür dass das vermutete multiversum genauso wie unser universum aus
Unzähligen schwarzen löchern besteht die universen gebären und auch vielleicht wieder verstehen wenn es neue erkenntnisse dazu gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier
Wenn ihr kein video dazu und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein aber aufs auge vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter. Also hiermit es gibt keine wirklichkeit multiversum da gibt es noch mehr infos zum
multiversum absolut mein blowing also darauf ab klicken und nicht verpassen ansonsten bis zum nächsten mal bis dann
bleib dran